Joyce's birthday is coming up this
Friday and she had a great idea yeah I
was like let's have a zero-waste party Z
Rosie Rosie uh zero Matt drinks yes we
do declaration know how a lot of buzzy
parties have large traps so I sent the
Facebook invites and I told everyone
doing it cut because Raziel waist party
is this summer for hours we gotta get
zero a snack so I'm just gonna get
raisins just getting her get other more
tasty snacks
go quick
forget a lot of chips
and like a mom trying to convince people
so I just bought six different types of
snacks for the party for 38 78 I'm
coming to my birthday party today
the party is zero waste we're in the
hillsides of Los Angeles and we're going
to be foraging for our zero waste party
decorations today gathering flowers and
we're gonna compost them after we can
compost the flowers why buy decorations
that will go to landfill lasts forever
when you can have free decorations that
are cuter than the plastic ones anyway
these are very majestic this is actually
way more fun than going to the store
it's very pleasant just gathering the
flowers on the hillside grace has no
idea what's going on
[Music]
I borrowed my friends Cape holder and I
go pick up a cake
I got a guava cake for choice the cake
costs $30 but here's the thing I feel
like somebody in LA would actually get a
lot of money for this so I brought
snacks only reusable containers that
brought strawberries I'm gonna put all
my moonshine in this bottle wow that's a
big moonshine but I like it lots of ice
this is beautiful fern we have an effort
oh okay okay
yeah ready to go see the zero we should
be rinse we've been up to
yeah okay let's go
amazing sincerely snacks the vehicle and
your roommate brought the branch and she
cut it up very beautiful Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
like season
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I am home now the party is still raging
but I'm gonna have sweet dreams tonight
thinking about all those Red Solo cups
that we did not send to the landfill
we're gonna look through the party trash
party party party trash party trash I
think you did pretty well let it be
known that this trash is not the trash
that we made making our zero waste party
and we did our best to ask people to
bring their own cup and not to bring
trash but you know people are people and
they brought some trash so we're just
gonna go through it I am excited about
going through trash so we'll set up the
recycling landfill and compost waste
sorting she's sorting things she's
sorting why I sing for pizza boxes you
can recycle the top if it's not food
soiled but anything that's food sold
can't go in the recycling so this would
go to landfill what about check bags
those are trash because they're mixed
material because they're plastic on the
outside and foil on the inside all the
stuff in front of us is compost and
recycling the final verdict is that for
a party of over 60 people this is all
the landfill we made it it's not perfect
but I think we did way better than if we
just didn't try to have people reduce
their trash at all yeah having people be
conscious about the mess they make even
when we are all tipsy and turnt
it's actually cool cuz mostly everyone
tried what do you think in terms of time
and money I don't know what you did in
terms of time I think it's the same
because I still would have had to source
decorations and the cake but I just did
it zero waste and in terms of money I
spent a certain amount of money that is
here and it wasn't not much it was thank
you guys so much for watching
please let me know in the comments if
you would have a zero-waste party just
like this I meant to eat we're gonna try
to go to the club let's just back it up
back it up zero waste back it up hey are
you bringing up hey break it up
[Music]